كان اقرب الى لقاء عاصف ذاك الذي جمع
رئيسه الوزراء الفرنسيه اليزابيث بورن
بوفد النقابات العماليه للتفاوض حول اصلاح
نظام التقاعد لقد اخفق الاجتماع وقرر
الطرف النقابي المغادره بعد اقل من ساعه
على بدء المحادثات
التقينا بحكومه متطرفه ومتحجره ومنفصله عن
الواقع هذه صفعه في وجه ملايين من الشعب
الفرنسي في الشوارع الذين يضربون ويعارضون
التقاعد عند سن الرابعه وستين هذه
الاستراتيجيه المتشدده عنيفه وغير مسؤوله
والحكومه بالتالي مسؤوله عن الفوضى
الاجتماع وهو الاول منذ العاشر من يناير
الماضي شاركت فيه ثماني منظمات عماليه
مندمجه في اتحاد النقابي وحضره وزير العمل
الى جانب رئيسه الحكومه
كان تبادلا محترما للاراء حيث تمكن الجميع
من التعبير عن انفسهم والاستماع الى بعضهم
البعض استمعت الى كل منظمه نقابيه
واعتراضها على رفع سن التقاعد وتمكنت انا
ايضا
[موسيقى]
المعارضه اليساريه يمكن ان يمهد الاستفتاء
على معاشات التقاعد في البلاد